David Boder: [In English] Paris, September the 4th, 1950...excuse me...Paris, October the 4th, 1946, at Grand Hotel. This is apparently the last interview in Paris. The interviewee is Professor Dimitri Michailovitch Odinets, ah...a professor of history, of Russian history, and educator, a former director of...ah...gymnasium, a professor of several universities and at one time a member of the cabinet of the Ukrainian regional government. He will talk to us in Russian. [Pause]
David Boder: [In Russian] Димитрий Михайлович, будьте добры, скажите нам сперва вкратце Ваши официальные, так сказать, ну, занятия или Вашу официальную карьеру, скажем, начиная с 19...эээ...12го года. Только в...так сказать, в маленьких фактических таких местах. Начнём с того, значит, когда мы вместе работали в Димитриевской Гимназии в Петербурге, на Невском. И Вы же тогда были нашим профессором в Психоневрологическом институте, так? Вам теперь что? 62 года?
Dimitri Odinets: 62 года.
David Boder: 62 года. Вот...тогда, значит, только в нескольких словах. Начнёмте с 1912 года и пойдём.
Dimitri Odinets: Начиная с 1912 года я был...сначала был преподавателем ряда гимназий в Петербурге, потом директором гимназии им. Столбцова – полноправной мужской гимназии, профессором Психоневрологического института, профессором на Высших женских курсах Раева. Со времени революции февральской 1917 года я был командирован Центральным Временным...я был командирован Временным правительством в Киев, чтоб там сделаться министром по великорусским делам, т.е. защищать русских людей от возможного украинского шовинизма.
David Boder: Продолжайте.
Dimitri Odinets: На посту министра по великорусским делам я пробыл около года и вышел в отставку после того, как гетманом украинским был избран Скоропадский – человек определённо правый уб...и реакционных убеждений. После этого меня избрали председателем Союза возрождения России, южного его комитета. На этом месте я пережил в Киеве около двенадцати революций, когда одна власть меняла другую. Наконец, в конце 20-го года, при приближении большевиков к Киеву я вышел пешком из Киева в Одессу. Пешком, ибо тогда не было железных дорог. И, наконец, из Одессы в 25-ом году, в самом начале, сделавшись пулемётчиком, окончив английскую пулемётную школу, я вышел в составе военного отряда, чтобы пробиться за границу. Из нашего отряда – три с половиной тысячи человек – осталось в живых приблизительно тридцать шесть.
David Boder: Пробивались Вы через какие войска?
Dimitri Odinets: Через большевистские войска. Да, приблизительно тысяча человек. В Румынии я был интернирован, но через месяца через два вместDimitriev е со своими...эээ...компатриотами, также интернированными, мы были выпущены и попали в Сербию. Из Сербии, где я некоторое время был директором гимназии русской в Белграде, я переехал в Варшаву, из Варшавы, наконец, попал в Париж, где и нахожусь в настоящее время. Деятельность моя в Париже заключалась в следующем: вместе с моим страшим другом, Димитриевым, мы основали в Париже Русский народный университет.
David Boder: Это был тот же самый Димитриев, который потом перенял, так сказать,...эээ...некоторым образом попечительство Столбцовской гимназией?
Dimitri Odinets: Тот же самый, который здесь был так же активен, как и в Петербурге. Кроме того, я был здесь председателем [пауза] Русского педагогического общества Франции, профессором и инспектором основанного нами здесь Франко-русского института, [неразборчиво] юридического факультета. Был генеральным секретарём Русского академического союза во Франции, каковым остаюсь здесь. Написал несколько книг. Это всё.
David Boder: Так. Хорошо, Дмитрий Михайлович, и в настоящее время Вы что, редактором...?
Dimitri Odinets: Я редактор газеты «Советский патриот», член Центрального комитета Союза советский патриотов, продолжая оставаться...эээ...генеральным секретарём Русского академического союза. Да, я забыл ещё...ммм...– председателем правления Тургеневской библиотеки, которая была вывезена и конфискована немцами.
David Boder: Так как мы на Тургеневской библиотеке, скажите нам несколько слов о ней, и в каковом положении это дело?
Dimitri Odinets: Тургеневская библиотека основана при непосредственном участии известного русского писателя, Ивана Сергеевича Тургенева, в 1876 году. Постепенно она пополнялась книгами...
David Boder: . . . она не была только книгами Тургенева, это была вообще библиотека?
Dimitri Odinets: Это была вообще библиотека. Публичная библиотека, которая постепенно разрасталась и сделалась, наконец, очень ценным книгохранилищем. Все крупные французские учёные [неразборчиво] там постоянно бывали. Бывали, конечно, без исключения и все тогдашние [неразборчиво] русские эмигранты. Среди этих эмигрантов известных постоянно бывал в библиотеке и Ленин в бытность свою в Париже. Администрация библиотеки выборная, ибо библиотека принадлежит всем подписчикам, и я состоял в течение трёх последних лет выборным председателем правления. [Пауза] Город Париж, ценя библиотеку, дал нам прекрасное помещение. Книг всех было к началу войны до 110 тысяч названий, таким образом, томов было значительно больше. Когда немцы появились в Париже, названию выдвигали автора.
David Boder: Да, да, да, объясните. [Неразборчиво]
Dimitri Odinets: Да. Название - это значит автор. Например, Гоголь «Собрание сочинений» - это одно название, но томов там много.
David Boder: 24.
Dimitri Odinets: Да, да, да. Может быть, и 24 – зависит от издания.
David Boder: Я, видите, всё вспоминаю «Ниву», которая издавала писателей в 24 томах.
Dimitri Odinets: Таким образом, Тургеневская библиотека сделалась самой богатой русской библиотекой за границей, частью касающейся старой, не советского издательства, а царского. После того, как немцы взяли Париж, ещё до войны с Советской Россией, они предложили мне как председателю правления у...от имени правительства...
David Boder: Немцы Вам предложили?!
Dimitri Odinets: Немцы. От имени правительства купить эту библиотеку, говоря, что...
David Boder: От имени немецкого?!
Dimitri Odinets: От имени немецкого правительства.
David Boder: Зачем им нужна была библиотека?
Dimitri Odinets: Представитель Розенфельда...Розенберга, простите, который посещал библиотеку нашу, с ней познакомился, сказал, что библиотека очень интересная, и что немецкое правительство желает в силу этого её приобрести. Полагаю, что они имели ввиду перевезти эту библиотеку для «Ост Ойропа Институт» Розенберга. Когда я отказался продать немцам библиотеку, [пауза] ввиду того, что она мне не принадлежит, и ввиду того, что я не хотел этого делать, на следующий день библиотека была ликвидирована. Часть книг нам удалось спасти, но девять десятых было увезено в Германию, где библиотека находится и по настоящее время. Только в самое последнее время нам удалось найти её следы...эээ...в Германии, в зоне советской оккупации, и можно думать, что с помощью нашего представительства здесь, мы эту библиотеку – или то, что от неё осталось, - всё-таки получим. Но пока это вопрос...
David Boder: . . . получите для Парижа?
Dimitri Odinets: Для Парижа. Но пока это вопрос ещё не...[неразборчиво] недостаточно быстро.
David Boder: Хорошо. Ну, теперь, значит, начнёмте-ка сначала. Будьте добры, передайте нам – я знаю, что Вы историк, - но я собираю, главным образом, переживания очевидцев.
Dimitri Odinets: Так.
David Boder: И передайте нам...эээ...и расскажите нам то, что произошло лично с Вами и Вашей семьёй, оценивая события, конечно, - Вы иначе не можете, - начиная...с момента...эээ...германского нашествия на Польшу.
Dimitri Odinets: В момент германского нашествия на Польшу мы...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Dimitri Odinets: Да, да, да....мы, русские, находящиеся в Париже, хотя в то время Советская Россия находилась в союзе с Германией, я...мы понимали, что война неотвратима и немцы неизбежны. Что рано или поздно немцы нападут на Россию. И вот тогда, в предвидении этих событий, я порвал...порвал со своим эмигрантским прошлым и в первый раз пошёл в Советское посольство, сказавши там, что я прихожу туда потому, что я убеждён, что России грозит опасность, и что как русский человек, в силу своего патриотизма, в этот момент я должен быть со своей страной. Я был очень хорошо принят.
David Boder: Как была фамилия посла тогда?
Dimitri Odinets: Посол Богомолов, но он находился тогда в Виши. А в Париже находился заместитель посла Лев Александрович Тарасов, исключительно милый и культурный человек. Мы с ним встречались несколько раз, и для меня сделалось совершенно очевидным, что в вопросах русско-германских отношений мы стоим на одной почве и говорим одним языком. Тогда я и решил, что мне надлежит вернуться к себе на Родину, заявил об этом Тарасову, и Тарасов предпринял известные шаги. Но это было поздно. Естественно, через несколько дней вспыхнула война. Немцы напали на Россию, и я остался во Франции, в Париже, где и нахожусь по сегодняшний день, не теряя, однако, надежды и являясь абсолютно уверенным, что сравнительно скоро я вернусь, наконец, к себе на Родину.
David Boder: Так вот. Значит, это было, когда началась война. Ну, что произошло, значит, когда немцы напали на Францию, и вот Ваша личная жизнь и жизнь...эээ...то, что Вы лично обозревали.
Dimitri Odinets: Когда немцы напали на Францию...
David Boder: То есть напали уже на Россию - эту фазу.
Dimitri Odinets: Когда немцы напали на Россию, то в тот же день утром я был арестован немцами. Они меня отвезли в главное отделение гестапо [неразборчиво] в Париже и предложили мне ехать с ними в Петербург.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Dimitri Odinets: В Петербург, потому что, добавили они: «Мы нуждаемся в интеллигентных силах». А как Вы знаете, интеллигенция там была уничтожена. «Так хотите Вы с нами ехать или нет? Или Вы предпочитаете навсегда остаться вне России?» На этот вопрос я ответил категорическим отказом ехать работать вместе с немцами, в результате чего был отправлен в концентрационный лагерь в Компьене.
David Boder: Компьен?
Dimitri Odinets: Компьен, где, предварительно просидевши в одном из дворцов. В Компьене я прожил месяц...около двух месяцев. И тяжко заболевши от недоедания, был отправлен в Париж в больницу, там же находившись под немецким контролем, в Валь-де-Грас.
David Boder: Хорошо. Дайте-ка нам кое-какие подробности. Эээ...т.е. они Вас не единственного из русских вызвали. Что сделали они вообще с той русской...
Dimitri Odinets: Колонией?
David Boder: . . . колонией, предпочитая очевидно, что под русской колонией нам приходится говорить отдельно о русских православных и о русских евреях. Или о русских христиан и русских евреях. Как велика была тут русская нееврейская колония в...эээ...когда война началась?
Dimitri Odinets: Когда война началась, то вся русская колония считала...считая русских евреев, вместе взятых, ибо мы в своей среде разницы не делали...
David Boder: Так.
Dimitri Odinets: . . . равнялась приблизительно сорока тысячам. Арестованных...
David Boder: Было русских сорока тысяч мужчины, женщины и дети?
Dimitri Odinets: Кажется, да. Цифры точные никто не знает.
David Boder: Да, да, да. Я именно хочу оценку. Я не беру цифры...такую настоящую цифру.
Dimitri Odinets: Арестованных нас было [пауза] пятьсот человек.
David Boder: Русских?
Dimitri Odinets: Опять таки, считая сюда русских и евреев. Режим...власть вначале для русских и...эээ...русских евреев был одинаковым. Мы жили вместе в одинаковых условиях, одинаково голодали и одинаково терпели от различных лагерных неудобств. Но должен сказать, что вначале режим, конечно, был в тысячу раз лучше, чем, скажем, режим в будущем лагере, чисто еврейском в Дранси, и тем более, чем режим в Бухенвальде.
David Boder: Так. [Неразборчиво] Ведь с точки зрения, так сказать, военной, немцы интернировали...эээ...граждан враждебных держав, как бы они интернировали бы их в Германии.
Dimitri Odinets: Так.
David Boder: Как американцы интернировали бы, скажем, немцев, у себя. Ну, да. Только они, очевидно, Женевскую конвенцию не особо соблюдали. Ну, дальше.
Dimitri Odinets: Но нужно иметь ввиду, что по бумагам мы все были белые русские.
David Boder: Что это значит? Антисоветские русские
Dimitri Odinets: Т. е. по бумагам антисоветские русские. Таким образом, соображения, которыми они руководились, были иного порядка. Какие были эти соображения, мы так узнать не могли, ибо никто нам не сказал, почему мы арестованы. И люди, которые были в лагере, были столь различны – по своему положению, по своим политическим убеждениям, - что найти какой-то общий принцип, почему мы были арестованы, для нас было совершенно невозможно. Так этот вопрос и остаётся загадкой. Очевидно, нас арестовывали по каким-то спискам, пришедшим из разных источников и составленных на основании различных поводов. Итак, я возвращаюсь назад. Нас было около пятисот человек: русских в узком смысле слова и евреев. И вначале мы жили в одинаковых условиях и в одинаковом режиме, и отношение немецких властей лагерных к нам было одинаково. Но это изменилось сравнительно скоро. Так как состав наш был очень, как я сказал, разнообразен по убеждениям, то нашлись в нашей среде, в среде русских в узком смысле этого слова несколько человек, которые подали немецкому командованию записки о том, что они не желают сидеть вместе с евреями.
David Boder: Так.
Dimitri Odinets: Очевидно, эти люди думали таким образом выслужиться. [Пауза]
David Boder: Ну, и что?
Dimitri Odinets: Выслужиться.
David Boder: Ага.
Dimitri Odinets: Перед немцами. [Пауза] После подачи этой записки мы были отде...евреи были от нас отделены. Нас перевели в тот же...в другую часть того же лагеря, за другую проволоку.
David Boder: За что?
Dimitri Odinets: За другую проволоку, без права общения. Тем не менее, мне, с которым немецкие власти как с представителем лагеря, тогда сносились – мне удалось перевести и всех евреев, которые остались на прежнем месте, к нам. Я указал немцам, что то, что они делают – совершенно...совершенное безобразие. Ибо среди евреев, которые остались там, есть люди глубоко принципиальные. Противники Советской власти. Есть люди, которые...на деньги которых образовалась в своё время добровольческая армия.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво, очень тихо]
Dimitri Odinets: Да, да, да.
David Boder: Ну, дальше.
Dimitri Odinets: В то время, когда среди нас есть люди некоторые...
David Boder: Добровольческой армией когда? Которая это была?
Dimitri Odinets: Первой, [неразборчиво] самой первой.
David Boder: Это...во время первой революции...во время первой войны.
Dimitri Odinets: Во время первой гражданской войны.
David Boder: Да, да. В 18-ом году.
Dimitri Odinets: Вот ледяной поход знаменитый, вот это тогда.
David Boder: Да.
Dimitri Odinets: И немцы склонились перед этими аргументами.
Dimitri Odinets: И евреи, наши коллеги по заточению, были к нам переведены в нашу половину...эээ...В той половине, где они были, оставив только французов, которых...которых немцы называли коммунистами - без достаточного на то основания, ибо проверки не было.
David Boder: Вы говорите, французские евреи?
Dimitri Odinets: Нет.
David Boder: Нет, нет. Но остались, Вы говорите, французы? Какие французы? Французские евреи?
Dimitri Odinets: . . . при покушении на немецких солдат и офицеров из этого именно отдела брали тех, кого расстреливали как заложника.
David Boder: Это было в Компьене?
Dimitri Odinets: В Компьене.
David Boder: Как далеко Компьен от Парижа?
Dimitri Odinets: Приблизительно 70км.
David Boder: Это что? Военное какое-то поселение или что это?
Dimitri Odinets: Мы жили в бывших казармах - очень запу...запущенных – каких-то французских воинских частей. Каменные бараки.
David Boder: Так. Что у вас были – кровати?
Dimitri Odinets: Вначале пришлось спать на полу, но приблизительно недели через две нам привезли железные постели, и мы спали на постелях.
David Boder: Так. Семьям позволяли приходить, письма позволяли писать?
Dimitri Odinets: Первые свидания были разрешены через полтора месяца заключения. [Пауза] Писать можно было [кашляет] два раза в месяц на открытках казённого образца, где содержание письма было дано заранее, нужно было только отвечать на поставленные...
David Boder: Вопросы?
Dimitri Odinets: . . . вопросы.
David Boder: Сохранилась у кого-нибудь такая открытка?
Dimitri Odinets: Нн...к сожалению, не могу сказать. У меня лично нет этой открытки. У меня лично нет.
David Boder: У семьи Вашей нет?
Dimitri Odinets: Нет.
David Boder: Так.
Dimitri Odinets: Жизнь мало-помалу организовывалась. И в нашем отделении, где было пять университетских докторов и два французских университетских профессора, мы скоро начали читать лекции. Читали утром серьёзные лекции, вечером – более доступные. Мы стали преподавать языки. У нас преподавались языки: французский, немецкий, итальянский, испанский, английский и русский. Каждое воскресенье устраивали концерт. [Пауза] Организовали прекрасную церковь, так как в нашей среде были художники. [Неразборчиво] сравнительно скоро немцы отобрали это помещение для церкви, сказавши, что оно нужно им для того, чтобы там хранить картофель. И действительно, приблизительно через неделю после того, как церковь наша была уничтожена, они привели туда...привезли туда три мешка картофеля.
David Boder: Скажите, были священники интернированы?
Dimitri Odinets: В нашей среде было три священника. И один старый, носивший [неразборчиво], большой постник. Он приехал в своё время из Советской России и, как не интересующийся совсем земными делами, не спешил отменять свой советский паспорт. По-видимому, он был арестован за свой паспорт. За что были арестованы другие священники – об этом мы можем только догадываться. Один, по-видимому, был арестован за то, что он явно помогал евреям, выдавая им различные церковные удостоверения, которые по их...по его мнению, могли избавить их от ареста и заключения. [Пауза] Ну, вообщем режим, повторяю, был не очень плохой. Но он ухудшался, постепенно ухудшался. Постепенно вводились всё новые и новые строгости. Но эти строгости с особенной силой обрушились у нас на евреев. Их стали выделять не географически, а по обращению. Например, когда приезжала какая-нибудь комиссия немецкая для опроса, евреи шли в последний [неразборчиво]. Им не давались никакие обещания. Но в первое время были случаи освобождения заключённых, и среди освобождённых в первое время были освобождены около 16 евреев, и пропорционально больше было освобождено больше русских. В августе месяце, в конце, заболев от недоедания, я был переведён в Валь-де-Грас, где подвёргся...где подвергся очень тяжёлой операции, пролежавши несколько месяцев без движения на постели. После того, как я вышел, поправившись немножко, я застал уже в отделении для интернированных ужасный режим. [Пауза] Мы были не больные...не больными, а действительно тюремными [неразборчиво]. Но опять же, хуже всех приходилось евреям. В качестве тюремного старосты, выборного – если можно так сказать, - я представлял в больнице русских, французов, югославов и американцев. Только англичане имели своего представителя. Вот в качестве этого представителя мне приходилось объясняться с немецкими властями по ряду всех касающихся заключенных в Валь-де-Грасе. И в том числе...
David Boder: Заключённых где?
Dimitri Odinets: В Валь-де-Грасе.
David Boder: Это что такое?
Dimitri Odinets: Больница.
David Boder: А, да, да [неразборчиво, очень тихо]
Dimitri Odinets: И вот тут я был свидетелями...свидетелем некоторых ужасных сцен.
David Boder: Так.
Dimitri Odinets: «Этот не мой муж! Что вы с ним, негодяи, сделали?!» И положение евреев у нас всё время оставалось таким же кошмарным. Наше положение ухудшалось, были строгости, но кроме грубых сцен, криков, [неразборчиво, очень тихо] мер остальных к нам не применяли. Эээ...после десяти месяцев заключения я был освобождён как больной, но опять-таки без объяснений причин. После чего жил в Париже, существуя на те уроки, которые я давал, причём каждая победа Красной Армии давала мне новых учеников, желающих...желавших изучать русский язык.
David Boder: Из французов?
Dimitri Odinets: Ученики были французы, голландцы, несколько испанцев, [пауза] два-три шведа и даже один турок. Все были, кроме немцев. Для немцев у меня не находилось времени, я отказывался.
David Boder: А скажите вот что: каким образом Вас освободили?
Dimitri Odinets: Освободили меня без объяснения причины. Так же, как и арестовали.
David Boder: Что, семья хлопотала? Адвокат хлопотал?
Dimitri Odinets: Никто не хлопотал. Никто не хлопотал. Я не хотел, чтоб кто-нибудь из моей семьи обращался к немцам с просьбой. Вот...кроме уроков вот эти годы я участвовал в подпольной антинемецкой прессе, в русской. Газета, выходившая в подполье, в очень тяжёлых и опасных условиях, называлась «Русский патриот». Это было вместе с тем и рождение новой организации, которая...часть которой потом вышла [неразборчиво] вот той организации, которая теперь называется Советский патриот, [пауза] заключает в себе свыше 10 000 членов и издаёт газету под названием «Советский патриот», редактором которой и директором я в настоящее время и состою. [Пауза]
David Boder: Ну, сейчас, значит, рекапитулируем немножко. Были русские, которые...эээ...коллаборировали с немцами?
Dimitri Odinets: К сожалению, такие русские были. Но я должен сказать, что интеллигентная среда, среда работников пера, представители науки, писатели, таких людей не было. Можно...
David Boder: Не было среди них коллаборантов?
Dimitri Odinets: Можно назвать два-три имени всего лишь из писательского или учёного мира, которые пошли вместе с немцами. Остальные держались очень стойко [помехи], предпочитая голодать, но не помогать врагам нашей Родины. [Пауза]
David Boder: Скажите, Димитрий Михайлович, [пауза] Вы мне как-то рассказали один эпизод о русском военном, который был женат на еврейке. Эээ...расскажите нам этот эпизод с некоторыми подробностями, пожалуйста.
Dimitri Odinets: Итак, я должен сказать, что значительная часть русских, может быть, большая часть, [неразборчиво] вело себя в отношении...в отношении...эээ...в политическом отношении очень хорошо и стойко. Но бывали и случаи другого порядка. Бывали случаи, когда русские люди...в этот момент мы...[неразборчиво] была там на очень хорошем счету. И вот этот русский...
David Boder: Он что, был военный или...?
Dimitri Odinets: Он был...в этот момент он не был военный.
David Boder: Ага. Ну да, он бывший военный.
Dimitri Odinets: Бывший. И он донёс немецким властям на свою собственную жену в сле..., сказавши следующее: «Это же...моя жена – еврейка. Она развращает моих детей». Но эти «мои» дети были также и её. По этому доносу она была арестована и заключена в самый ужасный лагерь, представлявший собой настоящую каторжную тюрьму в лагере – прославленный ныне лагерь – Дранси. Когда директор французской больницы поехал в этот лагерь немецкий и просил у немецкого коменданта отпустить на свободу в высокой степени полезную работницу его больницы, он встретился с грубым отказом со словами: «О чём Вы хлопочете, когда сам муж просил, чтобы мы арестовали её. Сам муж хлопотал о том, чтобы мы задержали его жену в её бледное...её вредное влияние на своих детей». Француз, директор больницы, не поверил, что нечто подобное может совершиться, на что комендант ему сказал: «Да что долго говорить. Вот Вам письмо». И показал это письмо. Такие случаи бывали. Бывали...[пауза]
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 168. The interview with Professor Dimitri Michailovich Odinets...ahh...in Paris. [Pause, whispers and laughter] We are going over to the next spool for some short...question and answer...for a short question and answer session. Paris, September the...Paris, October the...
David Boder: Chicago, July the 6th, 1950. The Spool 168 ends rather abruptly which very often used to happen. The continuation of the interview is on Spool 169. Since that part of the interview lasted only ten to twelve minutes we have decided to record it right on this same spool. This spool then will be 9-168 and 9-169A. Spool 169B contains some incidental conversations and songs taken during the last evening of my stay in Paris. Boder. This is part of the project M.H. 156.
David Boder: Paris, October 4th, 1946. [Pause] This is Spool 169, we continue the interview with Professor Dimitri Michailovich Odinets, which begins on Spool 168.
David Boder: [In Russian] Димитрий Михайлович, вот эту историю, которую [неразборчиво] военный, который донёс на свою собственную жену. Больше неизвестно, что с ней случилось?
Dimitri Odinets: Она умерла.
David Boder: Где?
Dimitri Odinets: В одном из немецких лагерей, в Германии.
David Boder: А скажите, а с ним что случилось?
Dimitri Odinets: Судьба его мне не ясна. [Пауза] Знаю одно, что в момент освобождения от...Парижа от немцев он был с очень крупными деньгами и ходил открыто по улицам Парижа. На него, тем не менее, органы освобождения обратили внимание, и одно время он был арестован. Дальнейшая судьба его мне не известна. По слухам, он всё же был выпущен.
David Boder: Так, а...так, а скажите вообще...эээ...дайте нам какую-нибудь картины вообще...эээ...насколько Вы могли обозревать или читать или как редактор газеты...эээ...Во-первых, этот «Советский патриот» тогда вышел из подполья?
Dimitri Odinets: Да.
David Boder: Так. И кем он теперь издаётся?
Dimitri Odinets: Союзом советских патриотов.
David Boder: Так.
Dimitri Odinets: Его центральным органом.
Dimitri Odinets: Выходит раз в неделю.
David Boder: Так.
Dimitri Odinets: Позиции его просоветские. Это не значит, что те, кто пишет там, является коммунистом. Там могут писать люди самого различного миросозерцания, но при одном непременном условии, чтоб они были патриотами своей Родины.
David Boder: Так, ну, а скажите, это...как вообще началась – Вы же пережили русские революции, знаете, - как началось тут во Франции это...ммм...пересортирование или вообще разбор и...эээ...регуляции, если хотите,...эээ...тех, которые сотрудничали с немцами? Что потом произошло в этом направлении...эээ...когда немцев выгнали из Парижа.
Dimitri Odinets: [Пауза] При каждой мэрии – это значит при 20 мэриях Парижа [неразборчиво] были основаны особые комитеты «Либерасьон».
David Boder: Так.
Dimitri Odinets: Эти комитеты составлялись из...ммм...представителей так называемого «Резистанс», т.е. те, которые с оружием в руках боролись с немцами. В частности, в среде этих резистанцев-французов было очень много русских. Много, конечно, пропорционально большинству русских. Некоторые из них – немало даже – награждены теперь знаками военного отличия за проявленную ими храбрость. Многие были убиты в этой войне, как здесь называется война [неразборчиво]. Так вот, эти комиссии [пауза] «Либерасьон» занимались тем, что они привлекали к ответственности лиц, себя компрометировавших с немцами. Конечно, на этой почве не раз возникали весьма крупные недоразумения, в особенности в первые дни, когда арестовывались люди иногда по простому подозрению или по недобросовестному доносу. Мне лично в эти дни пришлось стоять в возникшей уже организации «Русского патриота» во главе юридической комиссии в составе нашей организации. Эта комиссия занималась тем, что она рассматривала жалобы лиц, обращавшихся к ней с указанием на неправильность заключений или арестов. Я должен сказать, что французские власти с нашими заключениями – заключениями вот этой юридической комиссии, во главе которой я стоял, - в высокой степени считались. Так что этой комиссии удалось освободить немало невинных лиц, арестованных [пауза] по недоразумению. Но эта комиссия не занималась тем, чтоб она вылавливала преступный элемент. Мы только заступались за тех, которые такого заступничества заслуживали.
David Boder: Скажите, между прочим, что это вот, что мы видали в кинематографах и стрижки волос у французских женщин и так далее. Что это была за...
Dimitri Odinets: Это было, по многим мнениям, очень...ммм...нехорошая вещь. Но она продолжалась, к счастью, только несколько дней.
David Boder: В чём это состояло?
Dimitri Odinets: В том, что женщин, заподозренных или уличённых в близких отношениях с немцами – этих женщин обри...им обривали голову...голову, писали краской на щеках и на голой голове знак свастики и нередко возили на показ по улицам. За такой колесницей следовали толпы мальчишек, и вообще это зрелище было...эээ...во всех отношениях уж...ужасным.
David Boder: А Вы думаете, что это было неправильное выражение неродного негодования?
Dimitri Odinets: Я считаю, что эта форма была недостойная французов. И всякий американец, англичане, которые были тогда в Париже, истинно этим возмущались. По крайней мере, многие из них это возмущение высказывали. Это ведь делалось без всякого суда, это делала толпа.
David Boder: [Пауза] Так. А что Вы собираетесь делать в России?
Dimitri Odinets: В России я думаю продолжать свою учёную работу. Думается мне, что я смогу устроиться на кафедре в Тифлисском университете, или как теперь называют вместо Тифлис – Тбилиси по-грузински. Я не могу вернуться по состоянию здоровья в Ленинград, так как в результате всего того, что мне пришлось здесь пережить: одно время я был парализован, вся правая сторона у меня была парализована, теперь я исправился...
David Boder: Вы великолепно сейчас выглядите.
Dimitri Odinets: . . . я поправился, но, конечно, результат этой болезни сказывается. Это та цена, которую я заплатил, в конце концов, за пребывание в немецком концентрационном лагере.
David Boder: Димитрий Михайлович, вчера вечером случайно за столом мы заговорили о одной версии происхождения...эээ или расового происхождения евреев из России. Можете ли Вы мне суммировать этот материал?
Dimitri Odinets: [Пауза] Мне представляется, как историку, совершенно бесспорно, что громаднейший процент лиц иудейского вероисповедания, проживающих в России, по своему происхождению является не семитами...является не семитами, а тюрками.
David Boder: А тюрки разве не семиты?
Dimitri Odinets: Эээ...[неразборчиво]
David Boder: Так, дальше.
Dimitri Odinets: . . . а тюрками. Иудейская религия была распространена в правящих верхах хазаров. Хазары к VII веку представляли очень сильное и могущественное государство, расположенное частью на Кавказе, частью на низовье Волги. Престиж их был так велик, что с ними роднились даже византийские императоры. Ну,...хазары усердно занимались прозелитизмом иудейского вероисповедания.
David Boder: Каким...каким образом хазары сами стали евреями?
Dimitri Odinets: Этот вопрос был задан однажды советником Кордобского калифа по финансовым...Кордобского калифа по финансовым вопросам евреем Хасдай ибн Шапрут.
David Boder: Это в каком году было?
Dimitri Odinets: Это...около VII века.
David Boder: Ага.
Dimitri Odinets: Этот Хасдай ибн Шапрут написал любопытное письмо еврейскому...хазарскому царю Иосифу. Письмо было отвезено ему через всю Европу торговой организацией евреевской - евреи-родониты. Родониты от слова Родан, Рон - река. Она была доставлена...это письмо через Киев Иосифу, царю хазарскому и до нашего времени дошло как это самое письмо, так ответ...эээ...царя Иосифа и ответ также его финансового советника. Документы были найдены в 1912 году в каировской синагоге. И вот...ммм...когда ибн Шапрут спрашивал Иосифа, как случилось, что на востоке далёком есть царство верных, исповедующих истинную религию, т.е. религию иудеев. На это Иосиф ответил историческим сказанием о том, что однажды хазары попали в очень трудное военное положение. Явился некий юноша, опытный военачальник, который победил врагов. Этот юноша был иудейского вероисповедания, и эта победа произвела такое впечатление, что все верхи приняли иудейскую веру. Так говорит хазарский царь Иосиф. Точные сведения по этому вопросу не существуют.
David Boder: Ну, что-нибудь, чтобы Вы хотели сказать американским учёным [пауза] как результат Ваших...Вашего опыта во время войны и в Европе?
Dimitri Odinets: [Пауза] Американским учёным я бы мог сказать много. И прежде всего, что я, находясь долгое время во Франции – больше 25 лет, в условиях тяжёлых для научной работы, я искренне завидовал американским своим коллегам, которые могут в совершенно исключительно благоприятных условиях при поддержке общества, при поддержке американского государства, заниматься своей наукой. Как историк, я могу сказать, что [неразборчиво] американских историков имеется целый ряд имён мирового значения. Лично мне пришлось познакомиться с известным историком Шотвелле, который стоял во главе издания, многотомного, предпринятого институтом Карнеги «О влиянии войны на...эээ...жизнь страны». В данном случае, в отношении нас - русских учёных, в отношении России. И написал там...эээ...книгу на тему «Низшая и средняя школа в России в результате войны 1914-18 года». Шотвелл на меня произвёл самые великолепные впечатления как подлинный представитель [неразборчиво] научной мысли и как исключительно обаятельный человек.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview of great interest with...ah...Professor Dimitri Michailovitch Odinets, a leader of the Russian colony in Paris. Paris, October the 4th, 1946, Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording, taken at the Grand Hotel. [Pause] Professor Odinets wants a correction. He is not the leader of the Russian colony, he considers that he is one of possible representatives or leaders but the colony is by no means something a unified group of unique convictions, tendencies and interests. Well, we will make that correction.
David Boder: Chicago, July 6th, 1950. This concludes spool 9-169A. Two spools are on this reproduction, 9-168 and 9-169A. The other part of Spool 169 contains some rather irrelevant material. This reproduction is part of a project supported in part by a research grant from the National Institute of Mental Health, United States Public Health.